Smartphones are not allowed A child who doesn't have a sea otter
[music] It's a
landing,
but when I talked about that [ __ ], you were so elaborate The three of you were in Kyoto, weren't you?
[Music]
You won't partner with me this time
If you make me a magician, I'll use my magic to grant any wish I don't have any particular wishes and I
don't want to be a magician, so why are you
fighting
[Music] For
Ecchan's sake?
I love you,
so I want to grant your wishes to the New Mooners.
[MUSIC]
That's it now
Why did you do that?
Don't make such a scary face
I like both I'm water too I'll
give you one piece of advice Kohinata full moon
But you should
n't be involved in Granbell 6 anymore I'm not a wing to participate
There's nothing  I have
[music
] for you
[music]